breaking news out of the Supreme Court
Politico is reporting a leak of the
Supreme Court's opinion in Dobbs versus
Jackson Women's Health this is the
decision that could potentially overrule
Roe v Wade and Planned Parenthood be
Casey this is the decision that could
potentially obliterate the completely
fictional National right to an abortion
that was established in 1973 the leak
itself is shocking unprecedented you've
never seen this kind of a breach of
trust from the Supreme Court but from
the decision that we've got this is just
a 98-page draft of Justice Sam Alito
writing the opinion of the Court
according to this leak if the leak is
legit the Supreme Court is voting to
overrule Roe versus Wade and Planned
Parenthood vkc the court is voting to
overrule
National Abortion most important
decision in my lifetime if this is legit
from the draft quote Roe was egregiously
wrong from the start its reasoning was
exceptionally weak and the decision has
had damaging consequences and far from
bringing about a national settlement of
the abortion issue Roe and Casey have
inflamed debate and deepened division we
hold that Roe and Casey must be
overruled the Constitution makes no
reference to abortion and no such right
is implicitly protected by any
constitutional provision including the
one on which the Defenders of Roe and
Casey now chiefly rely the due process
clause of the 14th amendment that
provision has been held to guarantee
some rights that are not mentioned in
the Constitution
but any such right must be deeply rooted
in this nation's history and tradition
and implicit in the concept of ordered
Liberty the right to abortion does not
fall within this category until the
latter part of the 20th century such a
right was entirely unknown in American
law
the Constitution does not prohibit the
citizens of each state from regulating
or prohibiting abortion Ro and Casey
arrogated that Authority
we now overrule those decisions and
return that authority to the people and
they're elected representatives
obviously if this is legit obviously
this is the right decision it's right
constitutionally it's right legally it's
right morally there are two theories now
on how this got leaked one theory is
that it was a liberal uh a liberal
activist who is working for this Justice
Sonia Sotomayor Sotomayor is the
furthest left member of the court and so
a lot of the chatter is surrounding her
staff the second theory is that this may
have been a hack this went to the
Politico National Security reporter so
maybe it wasn't a leak from the court
maybe it was just someone going in and
finding it in the court emails I for one
suspect it was the former I bet this was
a leak this is the sacrament for the
left killing babies on the altar of
progress is their highest Sacrament
we're not talking about safe legal and
rare we are talking about abortion on
demand without apology shouted from the
rooftops people are shocked at the leak
they're shocked they say that that you
would have this kind of breach of trust
on the court I'm not shocked at all of
course they leaked the opinion these
people kill babies okay if you're
willing to kill a baby you're probably
willing to leak a document the only
purpose the only purpose to leaking this
right now
is to intimidate the conservative
members of the Court into changing their
opinion and protecting the license to
kill babies all around the country the
secondary purpose will be to pressure
Democrat legislators into making Roe
versus Wade the law of the land but the
chief goal here is to intimidate the
conservatives on the court do not let
them do it we knew there were going to
be Shenanigans now more than ever now
not just in my lifetime probably in the
last 50 years of politics now more than
ever is the time to hold strong I'm
Michael knowlesis the Michael Knowles
show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday from spaghetti Noob
who says hey Michael how do they know
that there are 150 female skulls in
Mexico
how did they know how those skulls
identified that's a great question how
do how do the leftists who are currently
losing their minds how how do they know
that women's rights are being threatened
isn't that so strange a lot of
biologists these days when you want to
know if we're certain that your home is
protected you got to check out ring
right now go to ring.com Knowles you
know about Rings video doorbell where
you can see and speak to whoever is at
your doorstep whether you're you're in
the home or at your office or on the
other side of the world you know about
Ring's alarm system I absolutely love
ring alarm well then the question is
have you gone pro you need to go pro I
absolutely love this product CNET calls
it a giant leap for home security with
ring alarm Pro you are protecting not
just your physical home from the bad
guys from Freeze from fire from flood
your windows your doors all that stuff
you're also protecting your digital home
because increasingly we're living Our
Lives online in the digital world so you
got to protect that you got a lot of
very valuable data coming in and out you
must protect the real world and the
digital world you can do it all with
ring it's extremely simple to set up
it's it's a great deal by the way on
their subscription you get professional
monitoring for the ultimate peace of
mind they have the the professional
monitoring call you you can request
Emergency Services you've got worry free
security right now to learn more go to
ring.com
that is ring.com protect yourself with
the guys that I trust ring.com Knowles
if this opinion is legit if the court is
voting to strike down Roe v Wade and
Planned Parenthood be Casey then Donald
Trump has already secured his spot as
one of the greatest and most
consequential presidents in the United
States
ever in American history
this takes us all the way back to
election 2016. the big debate over well
should we support Trump well Trump's got
some problems and he seems to have been
kind of liberal in the past but do well
but the judges but Roe versus Wade but
getting those conservatives on the court
well it's not worth it I don't think
he's going to really do it and the
judges won't hold firm if this opinion
is Real This resolves the question
this resolves the question because one
Trump ended up being a very relatively
conservative president much more
conservative than anyone thought uh
Trump did not turn out to be the crazy
maniac who was going to overthrow
democracy he didn't do any of that but
but more importantly he will have been
the guy
who got Roe v Wade overruled by getting
three judges onto the court
now what the libs want to do is leak
this so that one they can cause riots in
the streets too they can get death
threats to the conservatives on the
court that's what they're doing that's
what they're out for it's the only thing
that they could be out for
and as part of that pressure campaign
they'll be pressuring the Liberals in
the house and in the Senate to pass a
national law saying that that abortion
is a protected right now they don't have
enough votes for that right now
because you'd have to get over the
filibuster you'd need 60 votes in the
Senate that doesn't exist you're not
going to get Joe manchin to vote for
this I don't think you're going to get
Kirsten Cinema to vote for this so then
they'll have to get rid of the
filibuster all in order to to serve up
more innocent little baby sacrifices to
their their
Idol moloch that's what it's all about
they just are trying to kill more babies
can you when you put it in those terms
it's so sick it's so sick but it's a
Mania and it is their most deeply
cherished right quote unquote in the
country and so they're going to try to
do that and they think that this will
help them in the midterms
that's the that's the long game here
they think that turning this election
into an election about abortion is going
to help them I think they're wrong about
that I don't think there's any evidence
that this is going to help them I think
infanticide plays not nearly as well in
Peoria as they all think that it will
I mentioned yesterday on the show I said
I'm not making any predictions here but
I'm a little worried about the Dobbs
decision the reason I was worried is
because John Roberts suggested that he
was not going to write the opinion of
the court and I said I'm not making any
any predictions here about how the case
is going to turn out but it seems like
some things are a little off here it
seems like something so if this is the
case that Sam Alito is writing the
opinion of the Court
then we don't know who this very well
might be a 5-4 decision we just don't
know maybe Roberts is going to side with
the Liberals we're just we're not sure
that the thing we know right now though
is
this this draft was written in February
February 10th is what it stated
if this is the opinion it will be the
most important political development in
my lifetime really of the last 50 years
we're talking about 60 million babies
60 million we all use euphemisms when we
talk about abortion and Women's Health
Care and Reproductive Rights and and we
all use these we're talking about 60
million babies the number is
unfathomable how many people in this
country should be walking around right
now and are not because of this decision
in 1973. this is absolutely
earth-shattering stuff
and actually even beyond the question of
abortion this this leaked draft of the
the court opinion has achieved another
shocking goal which is all of a sudden
everyone's a biologist
all of a sudden you're seeing memes
again
no uterus no opinion
this is a war on women you're seeing all
these arguments from 10 years ago I
thought we didn't know what a woman was
katanji Jackson on on this now will soon
be on the Supreme Court
said that she can't tell what a woman is
because she's not a biologist all of a
sudden everybody's a biologist Sam Alito
can tell you what a woman is and all the
people reading Sam Alito can tell you
what a woman is
absolutely
earth-shattering stuff and I won't let
the libs get me down they're trying to
gum this up they're trying to pressure
the conservatives to switch
what the conservatives need to do right
now
just come out with the opinion
I don't know if it's in its final draft
this goes all the way back to February
so presumably it's in much better shape
come out with the opinion
if the opinion is substantially
different
from this draft
then we will know that the libs have
succeeded
at pressuring and threatening violence
that's really what this is about right
you you whip up all of the riots you're
gonna have a whole lot of mostly
peaceful demonstrations coming out with
Molotov cocktails and rocks and all the
rest of it
and it will make a mockery of our system
of government I never want to hear about
the the Norms our Norms are sacred
cherished Democratic Norms I don't want
to hear it from the left anymore I never
want to hear the stupid phrase January
6th this is
so much more egregious an attack on our
democracy than January 6th ever was it's
not even comparable it's not even
comparable the leaking of this document
I never want it I don't want to see any
more crocodile tears from the libs if I
see them I'm just going to collect them
in my leftist tears tumbler
the opinion is phenomenal news the lake
is really scary news especially for the
judges who are going to be threatened
now so now is the time stand firm guys
you can do it stand firm this is the
moment this is what we're all here for
and then we can celebrate with a nice
big delicious plate of good ranchers
right now go to goodranchers.com use
promo code at Knowles you know what I
had for dinner last night I'll give you
one guess it was good ranchers I loved
it it was the good ranchers better than
organic chicken with the nice garlic rub
sweet little Elisa put it in a nice nice
chicken chili it was absolutely fabulous
but you know my favorite thing from good
ranchers it's the wagyu Burgers you've
got to try the wagyu Burgers they're the
best burgers you're ever going to try
and right now you can get two pounds of
your new favorite burger for free for
free with code Knowles what is American
wagyu it's some of the best beef you're
ever going to try and by the way you
don't just need to use it for burgers I
mean it makes phenomenal Rich buttery
delicious burgers but you can use it for
anything you use it for tacos you can
use it for chili you can just eat it
just the meat which is something that I
do being of Italian extraction sometimes
a little fatty meat just tastes
wonderful uh really phenomenal delicious
stuff but all their stuff is great the
steaks everything you want two pounds of
free wagyu burgers and zero inflation
what are you waiting for use my code
Knolls or visit goodranchers.com
if you don't buy the meat in your house
then tell the person who does to grab
two pounds of free American wagyu
Burgers today before they're gone promo
code Knolls at goodranchors.com Knowles
the White House is really really focused
on disinformation and misinformation and
censorship and propaganda they're really
focused on controlling the narrative
last week the White House announced the
creation of this new censorship agency
called the disinformation governance
board and the announcement came just
days after Elon Musk made it clear that
he was intending to buy Twitter
specifically so that he could give
conservatives more freedom of speech on
social media you think that was a
coincidence I don't it's a little that's
a little too much of a coincidence for
me on top of it that the new director of
the new censorship agency is a woman
named Nina jankowitz who is not only a
partisan leftist Democrat but she's also
ironically or maybe expectedly we should
say one of the biggest purveyors of
misinformation in the country
specifically regarding Hunter Biden's
laptop she covered up for evidence of
the Biden family's crimes and yet
despite
all evidence to the contrary about this
woman and about this board the White
House is still insisting that the new
censorship agency will not be partisan
there's this woman Nina jankwitz who is
going to be in charge of the board she
has said that she thinks the hunter
Biden laptop is Russian disinformation
so should we look forward in the future
to her censoring internet traffic about
the hunter Biden laptop I think I noted
exactly what the objective of the board
is including continuing the work of the
prior Administration and the woman you
noted has extensive experience and has
done extensive work addressing dentist
information she has testified before
Congress testified in Europe she has
done worked closely with the ukrainians
and has unique expertise especially at
this moment we're facing oh okay all
right good well that that sounds great
and look there it's this is just totally
business as usual don't worry about it
but
if the disinformation board
is not around specifically to censor
political
disinformation
what exactly is it going to do
the Mandate is not to adjudicate what is
true or false online or or otherwise it
will operate in a non-partisan
apolitical manner it's basically meant
to coordinate a lot of the ongoing work
that is happening and what their focus
is the focus is on disinformation and
threatens the Homeland as I noted which
things like inciting things that would
incite violent extremism you know human
traffickers and other transnational
criminal organizations any efforts at
malign foreign influence anything that
would endanger individuals during
emergencies so a lot of this work is
really about work that people may not
see every day that's ongoing by the
Department of Homeland Security it's
just the the censorship agency is just
going to coordinate the ongoing work
that's happening whatever that means
whatever ongoing work is and it's just
going to prevent violent extremism and
it's just going to stop foreign
influence
what who could object to that now of
course the Democrats have been
baselessly accusing Republicans of all
of those things for years they made up
narratives about January 6th and they
had a years-long Witch Hunt based on a
hoax about Russian collusion and they
used all of that to shut up
conservatives stop us from speaking on
social media and ultimately to silence
the president try to undo the 2016
election so in practice the point of the
board is simple and obvious
is to keep conservatives from Gaining
political power
and the tactic they're using is even
simpler they're going to shut up
conservative communicators people with
big shows people with big platforms and
also just individuals regular everyday
conservatives who share their opinion on
social media they're going to shut up
all of us
before we can ever even get the message
out that's what they're doing
so they'll do it to Regular Joe Schmo on
the street with regard to his Twitter
account his Facebook account his Google
account and they're going to do it all
the way to the people here on social
media in the podcasting world and
they're going to do it on cable news too
which is why they're launching in major
attack on Tucker Carlson the New York
Times has just published a three-part I
think seven bazillion word expose
shocking undercover reporting on Tucker
Carlson to expose the shocking fact that
Tucker is conservative
so when when the lips come out and they
say we've got a disinformation board
we're not going to stop conservative
speech we just want to stop
disinformation the problem is they
Define disinformation and misinformation
as conservative speech so I'll give you
an example the New York Times is giving
up the whole game here
the New York Times says they've
identified five areas of disinformation
misinformation
where where Tucker Carlson is spreading
dangerous fake news okay what are the
five claims that Tucker has allegedly
made that are such shocking
disinformation misinformation that the
libs want to censor number one I've got
it right here it's right from the New
York Times
that there are accusations that there is
a ruling class intent on controlling the
lives of normal people and censoring
anyone who stands in its way
they're saying that's misinformation
the observation that there is a group of
people who have political power who are
trying to censor us
which they just told us there is if we
say if we repeat back to them what they
just told to us that's dangerous
misinformation
that's one that's the first thing Tucker
said second one replacement through
immigration
assertions that there is an intentional
effort to replace native born Americans
with immigrants that immigration takes
away the resources and power of
native-born Americans
is that controversial is that even up
for question now that the Liberals brag
about that there was a famous piece
Infamous piece in the New York Times
written by Michelle Goldberg saying we
can replace them
the New York Times and other liberal
Outlets have been bragging for years
about the demographic problem for
Republicans because Republicans do much
better among native born Americans and
they do a whole lot worse among
immigrants and so as the Immigrant
portion of the population explodes
because we're taking in a million legal
immigrants per year and 2 million
illegal immigrants per year probably
more actually this year that the
consequence of this is going to be bad
news for republicans and it's
demographic demise for them they've been
bragging about this for years
foreign
even though the majority of Americans
not just of Republicans
but a ton of Democrats too want
drastically less immigration legal and
illegal
the ruling class keeps pushing it
because it benefits them politically
the big corporations get cheap labor the
Democrats get easy votes and that's that
is that that's a shocking dangerous
conspiracy theory no that's
that's their published self-professed
strategy shifting gender roles argument
this is this is the third horrible
dangerous idea that Tucker has allegedly
talked about arguments that feminism and
challenges to gender Norms have
diminished masculinity contributed to
Falling birth rates and led to the
demise of traditional family structures
they redefined the family they redefined
marriage and now they're chopping off
kids genitals I I don't think that's a
conspiracy theory they're they are now
you now have Democrats from the lowest
level all the way up to the White House
crying jensaki was crying on camera
because the Republicans might not let
all of these perverts pump little kids
full of cross-sex hormones and sterilize
them she was literally shedding real
tears over that shocking dangerous
misinformation discrimination against
white people instances in which Mr
Carlson speaks of racism against white
people and plays down racism against
people of color there is only one race
of people that you well sort of one and
a half races of people that you are
allowed to legally discriminate against
in America it is white people primarily
and for whatever reason sometimes Asians
get lumped into this specifically when
it comes to college admissions Asians
get white privilege when it comes to
college admissions
but the only group that it is not only
legal but socially acceptable to
discriminate against is white people
it's called affirmative action that's
the policy the policy is treat white
people more harshly than other people
whatever you think you can defend the
policy you can oppose the policy but
that is the policy that's all that it is
and and furthermore if you go on
television right now and you say black
people are terrible I hate black people
or Mexican people are terrible I hate or
Asian people are terrible you you will
be ostracized from society but if you go
on television and say white people are
really bad they're evil they need to
apologize for their skin color you'll
get a show on CNN or MSNBC as a matter
of social mores it's the only group
you're allowed to insult and encouraged
to insult so it doesn't seem like a
shocking conspiracy theory to me and
then furthermore
this is number five that they accused
Tucker of destruction of society
warnings about the destruction of
society civilization and Traditional
Values we are transcing little children
I think we're I think we're there
I think we're about where wherever Sodom
and Gomorrah were I think we're about
I think we're turning that up to 11 now
okay if that was 10 I think we're
turning it up to 11. I mentioned this
not just to dunk on the New York Times
not even to defend Tucker though he's
he's doing a great job
I I do it to point out this is what they
call disinformation or misinformation or
mal information or whatever other
whatever other euphemism they want to
use to shut us up this is what they call
it
and and this is what they're considering
so when we say these things which are
all obviously true they are going to
censor us they're telling us that
they're going to censor us and yet when
we
say that they are telling us that
they're going to censor us that's
considered misinformation too
New York Times is furious and they're
focusing in on Tucker in particular
this is no accident this is no
coincidence that they're focusing in on
Tucker
there was a woman from the New York
Times Karen yorish who just went on
MSNBC to to talk about her her shocking
deep investigative report
which is that she watched Tucker's show
a few times this is the most popular
cable news show in prime time but she
went in because she's the only liberal
who's ever watched Tucker she went in
and she said what Tucker is saying is
much more dangerous than she
thought it's just we're getting we're
getting waves in politics okay
we get waves of political change and
sometimes in your life if you want to
feel better you need real waves you need
one more wave I'm so excited to talk
about a company that is really making a
difference for our nation's veterans
that is one more wave one more wave uses
surf therapy to help veterans stay
active engaged and connected the founder
of one more wave Alex West is a retired
Navy SEAL who noticed that for many
veterans especially those with adaptive
needs standard off the shelf surfboards
say that 10 times fast with Sally
selling seashells by the seashore a
standard surfboards were not working
okay well what did he do he created a
team of surfboard artists and surf
instructors to work with Grant
recipients to design custom equipment
for their experience level and physical
needs one more way of connects veterans
to their Global Network of Surfing
volunteers who Empower them to heal
through surf therapy from coast to coast
fresh Salt Air sunshine and the
exhilaration of flying down the face of
a wave to keep more more veterans coming
back for more since 2015 one more wave
has empowered over 500 veterans to find
healing in communities through surf
therapy by providing customized surfing
equipment and community
they need your ongoing support help fund
10 new surf Therapy Grants by going to
1mwave.com daily wire sign up to become
a monthly sustaining donor the average
veteran Grant costs 2 500 bucks every
tax deductible donation counts help us
continue to support those brave men and
women who have given so much for this
nation one the number one mwave.com
daily wire become a sustaining member
today one more wave is a 501c3 and your
donation is tax deductible 1mwave.com
for more information when the world goes
broke the daily wire builds Alternatives
that's why we've started our own
publishing company called DW books we're
proud to announce that one of the first
books that we're putting out is fiery
but mostly peaceful to 2020 riots in the
gaslighting of America finally available
for purchase today the book is written
by Julio Rosas who exposes the black
lives matter riots that broke out across
the country in the aftermath of George
Floyd's death from this for the Sham
that they were check out the trailer
the media Gaslight the American people
for all of 2020 as the riots unfolded
they did not give you the full story I
was there to avoid Kyle Rittenhouse race
on books chased in Seattle I saw all the
riots with my own eyes windshields being
smashed giant rocks that were being
thrown businesses that were starting to
be looted the crowd started to become
hostile
all the cops were trapped and surrounded
police were being ordered to to retreat
I experienced the the tear gas I
experienced the smoke this was very real
to me
the mainstream media they were trying to
call them protests CNN with that Chiron
saying fiery but mostly peaceful they're
trying to push a narrative of don't
believe Your Lying Eyes because they
were trying to appease them very
dedicated antifa movement that's there
when we read my book The Fiery but
mostly peaceful you will get the full
story you will learn what actually
happened during the Riots of 2020 and
what the media did not want to tell you
buy my book fiery but mostly peaceful
everywhere books are sold the book is
available for purchase on Amazon or
anywhere you buy books online so go
order your copy today we'll be right
back with a lot more
thank you
the Intrepid reporter for the New York
Times Karen yorish just went on MSNBC to
give her report about watching Tucker
Carlson's TV show a few times she says
it was it's way more dangerous than she
expected Karen I want to ask you what it
was like for you to watch all these
hours of Tucker Carlson's show it was
revealing in a way that I can't even
describe I mean I had no idea I had not
watched the show before this project and
once um once I did I realized that what
we
wanted to do
um would create would be to create an
immersive experience so that
the people
um
who read the New York Times who most
likely don't watch the show on a regular
basis could feel what it's like because
I think it's easy to dismiss
um to dismiss what he's saying as you
know just another cable TV News host but
he's he's way more powerful and and the
content is way more dangerous than
um I think what what anybody realizes
unless you're watching the show on a
daily basis
way more dangerous this is an important
word what do they mean by dangerous do
they mean it's going to threaten
people's physical safety probably not
the Democrats are not generally so
worried about that they just leaked for
instance this court opinion the purpose
of which was to threaten the physical
safety of the conservatives on the
Supreme Court we just spent two years of
mostly peaceful riots where the libs not
only uh rioted but encouraged the riots
we're not just talking about street
thugs that were going out throwing
Molotov cocktails we're talking about
Democrats in the highest echelons of
power supporting with their own money
and with their own voices the rioting
Maxine Waters saying get this was even
years ago this was at the beginning of
the Trump Administration get up in their
faces go find Republicans when they're
out in public go to their homes where
their children sleep and yell and push
back on them and say you're not wanted
here encouraging them
elected to Democrats you had plenty of
Democrats going in and supporting the
BLM rights Kamala Harris who's now the
vice president of the United States
allegedly Kamala Harris comes out and
tweets out a a fund to go bail out the
rioters not to bail out the mostly
peaceful protesters the mostly peaceful
protesters didn't get arrested
to go bail out rioters
staffers for Joe Biden did the same
thing so I don't think it's that
why are they freaking out now
they're freaking out now because they
might not be able to kill babies
wherever they want in America so I don't
it's not that kind of danger
we're not talking about real physical
Danger
we're talking about danger to the
political order so why are they going
after Tucker why aren't they going after
other conservative hosts on television
because Tucker is a little bit different
okay the Liberals are fine to tolerate
the old order of conservatives using a
very small array of talking points to
kind of seem like they're pushing back
on the Liberals but not actually
threatening their power they're fine
with that
they're ha the Liberals are happy to
have court jester conservatives they're
they actually need the Court Jester
conservatives they need the squishes
they even need the people who put up a
good show but then when push comes to
shove when the when the battle is really
getting intense kind of back down a
little bit they like that because if
they have court jester conservatives it
legitimizes the Liberals power but they
don't like it when the conservatives
actually threaten what they're doing
this is something that Tucker does
really well on TV this is something in
the world of podcasts that I really try
to focus on in this show this show is
not simply owning the libs I like owning
the libs I drink out of my leftist Tears
tumbler my first book was a blank book
called reasons to vote for Democrats I
am not above owning the libs I think
it's very fun but we've got to do more
than just own the libs and frankly if we
want to own the libs actually own the
libs and actually get some political
power back we can't just use the same
old Republican talking points we've got
to think a little bit differently maybe
about trade maybe about immigration
maybe about the way we use language
maybe about the way we wield political
power we've got to think a little bit
differently we need some tough love for
our side my book with words speechless
is in many ways tougher on conservatives
than it is on liberals because I think
conservatives have been playing into the
left's hands and we got to change that
we've got to go in and change our
tactics that's the same kind of thing
what I'm saying on podcasting it's the
same kind of thing Tucker is saying on
TV and he's saying it to about four
million people a night which is why the
libs are so upset
that's why they're going after that's
what the danger is it's the danger to
their political hegemony that Tucker is
really threatening they go after us too
I mean the Media Matters has tried to
get me canceled for years now
but it's something that Tucker is doing
Tucker right now just has the spotlight
on him he's the biggest guy on cable
news so they attack him
dangerous they're not they're not
talking about physical danger here's my
proof that the New York Times is not
worried about physical Danger The New
York Times just ran an obit for a
terrorist who died an American domestic
terrorist who was associated with the
leftist group The Weather Underground
this is Kathy boudin
here's the first
tweet about the obit from The New York
Times
Kathy Boudin who is a member of The
Weather Underground took part in the
murderous 1981 hold up of a Brinks
armored truck died on Sunday she was 78.
okay fair enough that pretty much sums
it up but then they deleted that tweet
and they changed it here was the new
tweet
Kathy Boudin a member of The Weather
Underground imprisoned for her role in a
fatal robbery but who later helped
former inmates died at 78.
uh that's a little softer
so they deleted the first one and put up
the new one because the New York time
readers and Leadership and editors felt
they were being a little too harsh on
the Felon murderer domestic terrorist
a woman who participated in this robbery
that killed two police officers in New
York one security guard and seriously
injured another security guard
though I'm not I'm not saying that we
need to you know Spike the football on
This Woman's grave but she was a
domestic terrorist and now she's dead
okay a lot of people die a lot of people
get obituaries I think the New York
Times got it right the first time but
they couldn't they it was too harsh the
left has too much of a soft spot for
domestic terrorists especially the
Weather Underground they've been fedding
the The Weather Underground for decades
now including this woman this woman
after she got out of the can for some
reason she was permitted out of prison I
don't know why if you kill multiple
people and you're convicted of felony
murder I think you should at the very
least stay in prison for life but they
let her out
and she became a professor at Columbia
University and she became a kid you not
the co-director and co-founder of the
Columbia Center for justice
for justice a a radical leftist
terrorist who actually acted on her
radicalism and killed people became the
director of the center for justice
lives fine with that soft on that
the date the danger for the libs is not
having leftist terrorists running around
on the streets the danger for the libs
would be not having the the leftist
terrorists running around in the street
the danger for the libs would be
changing the power structure such that
leftist terrorists don't get out of
prison don't get to teach at our schools
don't get to do whatever they want
that's the threat
to them
and they always focus on education do
you notice this Bill Ayers ends up
around education another Weather
Underground guy uh Kathy Boudin ends up
in education all the focus all the fight
is on education
why because because
classrooms are crystal balls and they
tell you what your Society is going to
look like in 20 years this is why the
New York Times right now is up in a
tizzy over the the the
plan of Republicans to ban a book from
the classroom the book is called gender
queer here it is
New York Times how a debut graphic
Memoir became the most banned book in
the country genderqueer what's it say
Maya kababi's book genderqueer about
coming out as non-binary you know a
thing that you can totally do because
that's totally real and not just made up
uh landed the author at the center of a
battle over which books belong in
schools and who gets to make that
decision
then it goes on to talk about what a
great book this is and how awful it is
that it's being banned in schools why is
this being banned in schools because
it's weird creepy gay pederast porn
that's why
it's not that it deals with difficult
themes that's fine I don't mind dealing
with difficult themes even in school
even in high school or middle school
frankly even in elementary school
depending on how it's done
but this book this is a comic book
that does not have literary value
that furthermore includes a scene about
a 14 year old boy daydreaming about a
little kid having sex with a grown man
and it's a graphic novel so it's it's
drawn out
that's just obscene that's just porn
it's weird creepy petterest porn
it has no business in schools well what
are you are you for Banning books uh
yeah duh I'm certainly for Banning books
in fifth grade
in elementary schools I'm definitely for
Banning books the libs are for Banning
books they banned the Bible from schools
for for half a century now more than
half a century
but of course I'm for Banning some of
these books I don't know who needs to
hear this I know this is this really
runs contrary to a lot of
talking points now especially on the
right
it is good to ban some books in some
circumstances here are people in history
who have been for Banning I'll go even
further here are some people in history
who have been for burning books
the apostles in the New Testament and
the Acts of the Apostles they burn books
they burn witchcraft books sorcery books
uh Plato Plato was for burning books
Plato was for burning the books of
Democritus
uh who else was for burning books and
Martin Luther was for
burning books I'm not Martin Luther is
not exactly my favorite guy in the world
being a Catholic as I am but he was for
it uh and then the Catholic church was
for Banning Martin Luther's books and oh
right every every civilization every
country in the history of the world
including and especially the United
States has banned certain books in
certain circumstances
it was the libs who who embraced this
idea that we should never ban any sort
of books in any context whatsoever if
you want weird gay comic book porn and
kindergarten that's your right darn it
we're a free and liberal Society they
were the ones who pushed this idea it
was always insane and that the great
victory for the left is they convinced
conservatives to adopt this language we
have never believed this there is
nothing conservative about it at all
don't do it it's absolutely insane
societies have the right to standards
and if we're not going to stand up on
this standard
we're not going to stand up on no
Illustrated pet arrest porn in
elementary schools then we don't then
there are no standards okay then we're
not conserving anything then to be a
conservative doesn't mean anything at
all what is it with the libs and the
kids they just have this sick obsession
with the kids they want to kill the kids
when they can't kill the kids they want
to castrate the kids when they can't
castrate the kids they at the very least
want to pervert the kids minds and fill
them with all sorts of weird
pornographic sexual confusion what is it
it's weird it's just weird okay
I'm not trying to take cheap shots here
if you're just an an onlooker taking a
look at the political scene it is weird
how Obsessed the Democrats are with
screwing with kids heads it's really
strange
okay
if there was a tweet going around for a
while that that had gone it had gone
viral and it said it's really not that
complicated they're just bad people who
want to diddle the kids or something to
that effect and I think it's not quite
that simple it's unfortunately it's more
ideological than that
and and in a way I think it it makes
perfect sense
the libs realize that in order to
transform Society
you need to shape Society in order to
shape Society you need to shape people
when they are most malleable when they
are most impressionable and the way to
do that is when they're really really
little
you're physically malleable you are
psychologically and mentally malleable
and that's what they're going after and
we should not let them do it
if if our ideology if our version of
free speech is such that it defends a
weird pet arrest porn in kindergarten
something is going wrong with our idea
of free speech
they keep doing it Tyra Banks is doing
this Tyra Banks the former Victoria
Secret model
is now producing a drag show for kids
here it is this is from deadline this is
the Hollywood trade paper
Tyra Banks two executive produce teen
drag series for Discovery Plus
the discovery plus is entering the world
of teenage drag shows with Tyra Banks
the Dancing with the Stars host and EP
is to Executive produce this thing for
the streaming service the series follows
five teens and their families as they
anticipate their biggest drag
performance at drag you taunt a drag
show designed as a platform for lgbtq
plus teens to express themselves
goes on every adult associated with this
should be in prison if if we lived in a
sane Society
then all the adults associated with
telling 13 year olds to little 13 year
old boys to put on a dress and stiletto
heels and dance sexually before a bunch
of grown pervert men all of those adults
would be in prison okay and not that
long ago the adults would be in prison
actually in practice in America I'm not
suggesting that we turn America into
Mussolini's Italy or something I'm
saying we turn America into America six
years ago
when we understood this kind of stuff
six years ago when conservatives were
saying you know I think there might be a
slippery slope if we normalize all this
kind of strange sexual behavior next
thing you know they're going to be
sexualizing the kids and what happened
the left said oh you're crazy you're a
paranoid crazy conservative here we go
again with your slippery slope fallacy
well here we go we're dead we're we're
slipping we're we're slipped I think I
think we're at the bottom of the slope
are we except whenever I think we're at
the bottom of the slope we keep slipping
down
even further
now
we are not merely seeing this out of
Holly weird we're not merely which uh
before we left La Jeremy would refer to
Hollywood as Gamora by the Sea okay
we're not just seeing it out of there
we're seeing it out of the halls of
political power as well we're seeing
this being pushed from the top of our
federal government
Richard Levine
who is a man who thinks that he's a
woman who is
the assistant Secretary of Health in
America
because we're living in the upside down
world because we are through the Looking
Glass a dude who doesn't know what sexy
is and is pretending to be the other sex
is
one of the top health officials in the
country
Richard Levine is is coming out with
full-throated support of
transgendering little kids
not just adults you shouldn't do it to
adults either but now he's pushing this
for little kids and his argument for it
is that medical professionals agree
about gender affirming care for kids and
a gender affirming is an ironic phrase
because it means gender denying gender
affirming care is when you tell a little
boy that he's a little girl according to
the libs which of course does not affirm
anything it only denies reality
here's what he said he says and this is
in an interview with NPR
in medicine there's an evidence-based
standard of care for the evaluation and
treatment of trans individuals whether
they're youth or adults
the standard is set by the world
professional association for transgender
Health oh okay Zelda you're telling me
that the standard of what a man is and
what a woman is is being set by the
transgender Lobby
um
does that make a lot of sense that
doesn't make a lot of sense to me the
last formal standards of care were
released in 2011 and we expect a new
standards of care in 2022. so they're
saying 10 years ago 11 years ago maybe
they didn't quite think that we should
trans the kids yet but now look it's the
current year it's the current moment the
past is always evil the presence always
a crisis the future is going to be great
and so now it's 2022 and we've decided
to mutilate little kids genitals okay
and that's just if you question that
you're a bigot and an idiot
there are many other standards set by
organized medicine for example the
endocrine Society
which is an international organization
of hormone specialists endocrinologists
that has a standard of care there have
been comments from the American Academy
of Pediatrics a society for adolescent
health and medicine from the American
Medical Association the American blah
blah blah blah blah all in support of
evidence-based standards of care for
gender affirming treatment there's no
argument
among medical professionals he says
about the value and importance of gender
affirming care
if the entire medical establishment
is now suggesting that we should conduct
experiments on little tiny girls and
boys and pump them full of unnatural
hormones and chop up their genitals if
that's the opinion of them of the
medical establishment
all that tells you is that the modern
medical establishment needs to be
dismantled that doesn't tell you
anything about the little girls and boys
doesn't tell you anything about sex
about the difference between men and
women doesn't tell you anything about
medicine it tells you everything you
need to know about the political lobbies
that constitute the modern medical
establishment that need to be dismantled
Brick by Brick by Brick and these people
need to get help
okay they need to not be making Health
Care policy and they need to get help if
you're a man who thinks that he's a
woman you need to take a pause not be
making Health Care policy for the
country and go see a psychologist and
and work this out in your head I'm I say
this actually with a great deal of
sympathy and with as much compassion as
I can something's not right with you
you're sick in the head and you need to
get better
and you need to not
force your psychological problems on the
country
and especially
you need to not force your psychological
problems on little kids
okay we just need to say no
you got to say no to the pederasty
Illustrated porn in kindergarten okay we
got to say no to the sexually confused
people trying to transgender the kids we
got to say no to killing the babies
based on a completely made up
constitutional right from 19 we just got
to say no okay
and there's nothing fascist or illiberal
or a threat to democracy about that no
matter what the New York Times wants to
say no matter what the Thugs who are
about to be mostly peacefully protesting
with Molotov cocktails have to say about
it we need to stand firm okay the fact
that we're getting a lot of pushback
right now from the left on really basic
stuff don't kill babies and don't trans
the kids we're getting so much pushback
from the left on that that is going to
impel a lot of squishy conservatives to
say hey guys can we just give it up uh
do we have to fight about this this
might this might hurt us in the midterms
spoiler alert it's not going to hurt you
in the midterms it's going to help you
look what happened in Virginia look what
happened in Florida no one cares about
cutting your stupid corporate tax rates
everyone cares about protecting their
kids this is actually a winner for
conservatives but that's a political
calculation that's actually secondary to
the moral calculus it what we're doing
is the right thing to do and what the
libs are doing is the wrong thing to do
and the facts that they're pushing back
so hard tells you everything you need to
know that this is the fight we've got to
fight
well what are you are you really going
to die on the hill of or are you willing
to die I don't intend to die on any
Hills by the way are you willing to die
on the hill of not having pet arrest
foreign in kindergarten
yeah I guess so
I'm I'm certainly willing to fight on
that Hill I don't intend to die on any
Hills are you you're right you're really
gonna you're willing to die on the hill
of not killing over 800 000 babies a
year through abortion
yeah of course I am
oh my come on Mike you're really you're
gonna die on the hill of not letting
extremely Disturbed sexually confused
men make Health Care policy for all of
America and and try to pump a little
kids full of cross-sex hormones
uh-huh yeah yeah I am why aren't you
well because we need to focus on the
more important battles like tariffs
like oh oh okay all right sorry okay all
right fine uh no
that's that's the old way that's the old
way of fighting the political battles
that the New York Times was basically
fine with you know they would push back
a little but that was fine that all
worked within the framework of
liberalism
they didn't they didn't really call that
dangerous and a threat to democracy and
try to upend elections and try to
you know pull threats on the members of
the Supreme Court for that stuff okay
they would complain they would whine no
no citizens united is going to change
campaign Finance law even DC versus
Heller is going to change gun control
law
you didn't see this stuff okay
you didn't see activists on the court
releasing opinions trying to put a
Target on the heads of these justices
you didn't see seven bazillion word long
New York Times exposes trying to go
after people for stating basic truths
about reality
the the only thing this is a rule of
Show Business the only thing worse than
being talked about is not being talked
about okay and in politics the only
thing worse than being attacked by the
really bad people is not being attacked
by the really bad people at the New York
Times or in the white house or anywhere
else okay the fact that it's getting so
hot right now tells you how important an
issue this is these issues that we're
fighting right now are of such
importance don't go squishy now I'm
Michael Knowles this the Michael Knowles
show see you tomorrow
[Music]
the Michael Knowles show is produced by
Ben Davies executive producer Jeremy
boring supervising producer Mathis
Glover production manager Pavel vidovsky
editor and Associate producer Danny
D'Amico associate producer Justine
Turley audio mixer Mike coromina and
hair and makeup by Cherokee heart
Michael Knoll show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2022.
hey there this is John Bickley daily
wire editor-in-chief and co-host of
morning wire on today's episode crime in
major cities spins out of control the
newly formed disinformation governance
board comes Under Fire and the Supreme
Court hands down a unanimous decision on
free speech and religious liberty join
us and get the facts first on the news
you need to know with our show morning
wire